so this is your fourth time here so
since you look so fabulous
um our every time someone has been here
four times we give them a little present
you're going to look real good in this
week
maybe get you the
[Applause]
i have a smallest so i can put this on
in my convertible car oh my god and
drive i'm a little cute girl and i'm
manifesting a date
and my team kelly jackson jacket yes
baby
yes all right so you're your friend and
two funny mama's co-host kim whitley
she's also been here four times
and i hear that are you each other's
like emergency contact like in case of
an earthquake
girl the last earthquake the last two
earthquakes that happened i called kim
up and i was so scared because i'm
traumatized from earthquakes
because the big one that we had back in
1995 somewhere around there
i was on a booty call and that was the
worst because
i thought that jesus christ was coming
it was like boom boom
and i realized oh my gosh jesus is
coming he gonna knock on my door i'm
gonna booty call with somebody i don't
even
like first of all so i made him get on
the floor we were butt
naked and we were praying for
forgiveness through the whole earthquake
i was so traumatized so that's all i
remember
is being on a booty call earthquakes
mean booty call bad booty call
so i'm just like so whenever we have an
earthquake i call up kim
and i'm like you just got to walk me
through this girl yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever